you have a podcast I really like called
snafu thank you and it's uh
it's very well done it's really well
written uh and produced and it's telling
the stories of
um well in this season that I've been
listening to this really scary thing
that happened in 1983 that I didn't even
know about and this is going to be the
series you can do you'll be doing
multiple seasons and multiple shows
about various things that have gone
horribly wrong that we've probably that
we probably don't know about is that a
fair so the the log line of the podcast
is it's called snafu and the log line is
it's just about History's Greatest
screw-ups and so as you mentioned season
one is dedicated entirely like each
season will be dedicated entirely to one
thing season one is is a cold war
disaster called uh Able Archer 83 and uh
like you I didn't know about it either
and it's kind of and the more I went
down the rabbit hole I was just like
good God this is so important like it's
it's a it's a fascinating and Darkly
very Darkly hilarious story about how we
almost
reached nuclear Armageddon in 1983 due
to like poor judgment miscommunication
and lots of mistakes yes
um but uh it's pretty I mean it is
chilling because and and the season
starts out with you you actually get to
talk to it's cool you're talking to
Matthew Broderick but a very influential
big hit movie came out that year called
war games that movie came out in the
spring of 1983 and Abel Archer 83
happened in November of 1983 so it was
like predicting the future it really is
this eerily similar chain of events this
fictional Hollywood movie and then
reality plays out like eight months
later and uh yeah just for a little more
clarity basically
um
there uh there's this NATO exercise that
happened every year called Abel archer
in in 1983 uh this military exercise for
various reasons was perceived by the
Soviet Union to be an actual staging by
the West for a nuclear attack on the
Soviet Union so the Soviet Union
responds by ramping up their nuclear
posture
all of this is a misunderstanding on
both parts and uh there's some
fascinating really wild Espionage going
on at the time that we get deep into in
the in the podcast
um and again there are these very Darkly
funny misunderstandings but they're only
funny because the stakes are so high
that all you can do is laugh right it's
awesome we can laugh now because it's
you know
2022 23 whenever this airs and uh we
know
that okay that didn't happen chuckle but
it's terrifying at the same time it and
and what I also love about the story is
that it's it's also a story of heroism
because the the
historians that exposed this story it
was secret for decades and the CIA
really tried to keep this under wraps
um but a few historians really dug deep
and you know through Freedom of
Information Act requests uh
were a like over years like very
tenacious work we're able to bring this
story to light and and expose it for
what it is and thank God because it's
unacceptable right that's what that's
what's so terrifying it's like
any any risk of nuclear war is
unacceptable the stakes are cataclysmic
and when you're seeing behavior that
somehow this clumsy I think one
historian uh makes the analogy of two
drunks circling each other in a bar you
know and and
uh it's it needs it needs sunlight it
needs to be exposed it needs to be
talked about it needs to be analyzed so
that we don't repeat it yeah and and
obviously that's I'm not saying that
secrecy isn't important it of course
plays an important role in in uh in
government Affairs and and and and
international whatever all the CIA stuff
it's a lot of secret stuff that should
be secret but then oftentimes secrecy
gets used really just as a way to
perpetuate impunity and that's not okay
and that's where I think the the
historians really shine on this in this
story
um by bringing this whole thing to light
and it's it was so fun to do I say this
all the time about uh this podcast
phenomenon
it's fun it is really fun to get to do
this I mean this is a way for you to
follow your passion
history but it's also uh there's a real
nice comedic element that's appropriate
at times you know it's like you you got
it's well balanced it's really well
produced but you get to have these
passion projects that
you know you can make and I think a lot
of people are going to uh really enjoy
this
um it's called snafu and it's available
uh everywhere you get your podcast I
love saying that because I never know
really what it means wherever you get
your putts like what do you mean you
know yeah the
podcasts yeah not cheap